why do we cringe when we hear
Shakespeare if you ask me it's usually
because of his words all those vines and
boughs and therefore sand wherefore art
those can be more than a little annoying
but you have to wonder why is he so
popular why if his plays been made and
remade more than any other playwright
it's because of his words back in the
late 1500s and early 1600s that was the
best tool that a person had and there
was a lot to talk about however most of
it was pretty depressing you know with
the Black Plague and all Shakespeare
does use a lot of words one of his most
impressive accomplishments is his use of
insults they would unify the entire
audience and no matter where you sat you
could laugh at what was going on onstage
words specifically dialogue in a drama
setting are used for many different
reasons to set the mood of the scene to
give some more atmosphere to the setting
and to develop relationships between
characters insults do this in a very
short and sharp way let's first go to
Hamlet right before this dialogue
Polonius is the father of Ophelia who is
in love with Prince Hamlet King Claudius
is trying to figure out why Prince
Hamlet is acting so crazy since the King
married Prince Hamlet's mother Polonius
offers to use his daughter to get
information from Prince Hamlet then we
go into act 2 scene 2 Polonius do you
know me my lord Hamlet excellent well
you're a fishmonger Polonius not I my
lord Hamlet then I would you were so
honest a man now even if you did not
know what fishmonger meant you can use
some contextual clues 1 Polonius reacted
in a negative way so it must be bad to
fish smell bad so it must be bad and 3
manga just
doesn't sound like a good word so from
not even knowing the meaning you're
beginning to construct some
characterization of the relationship
between Hamlet and Polonius which was
not good but if you dig some more
fishmonger means a broker of some type
and in this setting would mean like a
pimp like Polonius is brokering out his
daughter for money which he is doing for
the Kings favour this allows you to see
that Hamlet is not as crazy as he's
claiming to be and intensifies the
animosity between these two characters
want another example Romeo and Juliet
has some of the best insults of any of
Shakespeare's plays it's a play about
two gangs and the star-crossed lovers
that take their own lives well with any
fifty cuffs you know that there is some
serious smack talk going on and you are
not disappointed in act 1 scene 1 right
from the get-go we are shown the level
of distrust and hatred the members of
the two families the Capulets and
Montague's meet Gregory I will frown as
I pass by and let them take it as they
list Sampson nay as they dare I will
bite my thumb at them which is a
disgrace to them if they bear it enter
Abraham and Balthazar Abraham do you
bite your thumb at us sir Sampson I do
bite my thumb sir Abraham do you bite
your thumb at us sir
okay so how does this development help
us understand mood or character well
let's break it down to the insult biting
your thumb today may not seem like a big
deal but Samson says it is an insult to
them if they take it so it must have
been one this begins to show us the
level of animosity between even the men
who work for the two houses and you
normally would not do anything to
someone unless you wanted to provoke
them into a fight which is exactly
what's about to happen
looking deeper biting your thumb in the
time in which the play was written is
like giving someone the finger today a
pretty strong feeling comes with that so
we now are beginning to feel the tension
in the sea
later on in the scene tabled from the
house of the Capulets laser good one on
Benvolio from the house of the Montagues
tibalt what art thou drawn among these
heartless Hinds turn thee Benvolio
and look upon thy death Benvolio I do
but keep the peace put up thy sword or
manage it to part these men with me
tibalt what drawn and talk of peace I
hate the word as I hate hell all
Montague's and thee have at thee coward
ok heartless Hinds well we know that
once again it's not a good thing both
families hate each other and this is
just adding fuel to the fire but just
how bad is this stinger a heartless hind
is a coward and calling someone that in
front of his own men and the rival
family means there's going to be a fight
Tybalt basically calls out Benvolio and
in order to keep his honor Benvolio has
to fight this dialogue gives us a good
look at a characterization between these
two characters Thibault thinks that the
Montagues are nothing but cowardly dogs
and has no respect for them once again
adding dramatic tension to the scene ok
now here's a spoiler alert t-bolts
hotheadedness and severe hatred of the
Montagues is what we literature people
call his ha Marsha or what causes his
downfall oh yes he goes down at the
hands of Romeo so when you are looking
at Shakespeare stop and look at the
words because they really are trying to
tell you something
you